bienvenue à vous tous on va tout de
suite écouter anthony blinken le chef de
la diplomatie américaine des affaires
étrangères
à tous nos collègues qui ont reçu qui
nous ont accueillis
je suis ravi également que notre nouvel
ambassadeur soit arrivé
le mois dernier c'était pour nous cela
nous a permis de confirmer cet
ambassadeur ce qui est très important
en particulier aujourd'hui
depuis le début des relations
diplomatiques entre nos pays il ya
trente ans n'ont jamais été confrontés à
un défi aussi quand que celui
d'aujourd'hui
la guerre
injustifiée non convoqué de la russe a
entraîné une crise humanitaire qui a
déjà fort impact sur la région y compris
ici dans la république de moldavie
240000 ukrainiens ont fui leur pays pour
rejoindre la moldavie fuyant pour pour
vivre des femmes et des enfants et les
ce chiffre va augmenter
comme je le dis à madame la présidente
la moldavie méritent nos remerciements
pour avoir accueilli et protégé ces
ukrainiens
comme nous en avons parlé aujourd'hui
les états unis vont faire tout ce qui
est en notre post ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour aider la moldavie qui aide
ces personnes qui ont déjà traversé tant
de difficultés notre administration a
demandé au congrès 2,75 milliards de
dollars en aides urgentes humanitaire à
la fois pour aider ces personnes en
ukraine mais également pour aider les
réfugiés en moldavie pour aider la mode
habib al hayr cueillir ces réfugiés
ukrainien
la communauté internationale a également
la responsabilité d'aider la moldavie à
se défendre nous allons respecter notre
engagement au sein d'organisations
internationales
l'invasion russe en ukraine est une
violation de la souveraineté de ce pays
l'a vu une violation de l'intégrité
territoriale du pays une violation
de la charte des nations unies et bon
nombre de pays se sont opposés
les états unis souhaitent exprimer leur
plein soutien pour la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de tous les
pays y compris la république de moldavie
les pays ont le droit de choisir leur
propre avenir
la moldavie a choisi la voie de la
démocratie
une collaboration plus une relation plus
proche avec les autres pays d'europe les
etats unis soutiennent le choix de la
moldavie
dans le respect de la constitution
notre partenariat est confrontée à des
défis
aujourd'hui
nous avons d'autres sujets sur lesquels
nous devons travailler c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette guerre choisie est
une catastrophe elle détourne notre
attention des sujets sur lesquels nous
devons travailler les etats unis
ont déployé des centaines de milliers de
vaccins en moldavie et ont aidé la
population à faire face à la pandémie
nous allons investir à 18 millions de
dollars pour les années à venir pour
aider à renforcer le secteur énergétique
de la moldavie le diversifier ce qui
était essentiel pour votre souveraineté
nous soutenons les négociations au sein
de la bce pour
trouver une résolution pacifique au
conflit en transnistrie
afin de lui trouver peut-être un statut
spécial et nous chercherons en
permanence à renforcer nos liens avec
les pays des liens économiques en
matière d'éducation des liens personnels
également car nous souhaitons que notre
relation avec le peuple de moldavie soit
encore plus fort face à au défi
international auquel nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui nous allons
obtenir de meilleurs résultats si nous
travaillons ensemble avec nos
partenaires en particulier des
partenaires démocratiques
nous savons nous savons qu'il est
important de travailler avec des pays
qui respecte l'état de droit respecte la
démocratie travailler avec ses
partenaires est le meilleur moyen
d'atteindre de bons résultats si nous
allons soutenir la république de
moldavie
dans sa lutte contre la corruption pour
mettre des réformes démocratiques des
réformes démocratiques
renforcer son secteur judiciaire et pour
avoir des médias indépendants qui
permettent de diffuser des informations
fiables et lutter contre la
désinformation
le monde entier fait front pour défendre
les valeurs démocratiques et la moldavie
est un bel exemple de démocratie
avec une vision et une détermination
sans faille ce partenariat entre nos
pays repose sur des intérêts partagés et
des valeurs partagées nous sommes
reconnaissants envers la moldavie pour
son amitié nous avons hâte de d'avoir
encore trente ans d'amitié avec vous
merci beaucoup pour votre générosité
envers le peuple ukrainien en ce moment
difficile pour la démocratie et la paix
merci
[Musique]